every esport has that one flashy role
whose residents
are rock stars mechanical maestros whose
sole responsibility is to ship out
savory beatdowns
is the triple off the rocket is the
fourth kill he's working on the ac
that's an absolutely monstrous
performance there on short a in mobas
like league and dota you have the mid
laners in siege it's the utterly brain
dead ash and jaeger mains hell even
overwatch boasts a handful of heroes
whose specialists
actually have to you know aim and the
fight is there prophet gets the head
shot gets rid of the tracer and the
shocker only worked with five players
that's gonna be hard from off the
resurrector's wall i think they just
wait for him to return and
prophet are you kidding me and lord
knows
in counter-strike
it's the offers why don't you cast the
round okay tax up one he's gonna get
back
i'm starting to believe as well henry
because he's gonna take conflict
stop blowing my mind from the flicks to
the filthy no-nos there is no denying
that those who've been entrusted with
the mighty green are the showstoppers of
cs
living breathing highlight reels who
will stop at nothing to churn out the
most ludicrous clips imaginable try and
hold off the rotations oscar's gone
chris isn't up still in the picture oh
i'm still very much in the realm oh
chris he's found three it's down to it
two one two chris can he close this with
an ace oh my god chris the wolf of wall
street gets an ace
well i mean
all of them
save
one stay steady james timer uh yeah
i can't vote
today we're here to pay our begrudging
respects to jaime james ali the
enigmatic opera who's managed to cement
himself as world class
not by taking fights but by avoiding
them time
and time again and i think we know what
time it is ak-47 in hand and there's
nowhere to be seen in the action
no so the save streak
begins and jim last man standing awp in
hand
you know he'd love to save the weapon
he'd love to he loves a good save you
see despite being a more than capable
fragger james go-to instinct is never to
lunge into battle
it's to play with such passivity that at
the first sign of failure he opts to
retreat instead of retake
to save
instead of slam to instigate what the
community calls
[Music]
and because of his passive play style
james has unwittingly cemented himself
as not only the most meme-don opera in
existence
but maybe the most maligned
with no other option but to save
[Applause]
i think he might be out of time already
he's hunting him and holds circus toying
with him he's gonna get the kill but not
the round
can he live here there's no way oh he
does just 15 damage what an absolute
troll
so how is it that jane became the most
anti-climactic
opera alive in what sense has his roster
built this boring yet extremely
effective play style around him and why
has it turned them into one of the best
teams in the world james 1v2 and no jane
time left in the tank he's gonna win
this there's the first oh
shame with the double and it keeps on
going for vp
[Music]
now before you nab the awp you'll see ya
nerds and bunny hop your way off site be
sure to like the video subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications that
way i'll have even more money to buy
even more ops and more importantly
op skins
gong mirrors don't grow on trees you
know alright so who is jame and how did
he become the messiah-like opera in-game
leader and face of the all too
vitriolized vertice pro well like a lot
of crispy counter-strikers our boy hails
from the motherland that is the cis
where he signed to his first real roster
avangar in 2017
by 2018 avangar were fragging their way
into some very hefty international
events such as the boston major and
james was quickly cementing himself as
not only one of his region's breakout
stars but one of his game's slowest
steadiest and most surgical offers again
the support may be good but he's left on
his own for now one kill comes in cody
quick with the trade and avant-garde
pulling it back man for man as they
continue the fight davecross can try and
stop the bomb down and now with 15
seconds left all it takes is one kill
although this time it goes in the favor
of james trey from sock pick on the
flank and it's all down to whether he
plants seven seconds left goes for the
safe option and i like it but that'll
just allow sotvic to push up
aggressively switches up to the box as
he moves on him but spotted on the jump
and james hits the shot 12 rounds for
avant-garde and by all accounts that's
exactly what an opera should be reserved
and for the most part risk-averse
it just so happens that jane boasted one
quirk that took that
to a whole other level you see jane
loved his own
like a lot
so much so that he always saved it
always the one issue that they will have
though is james because he's bought an
off glass cannon
another one of those strange of anger
buys where it just doesn't make sense
you might as well do it now though
because it doesn't seem like you have a
car too intent on on going for a retake
and hemp is definitely going to be
surprised by that look it's like why are
they going up yeah
at least remain honest but yeah avangar
immediately deciding to save they've uh
backed the hell out now you might be
thinking
isn't that a good thing as anyone who's
ever reluctantly dropped an op will tell
you
if you blow nearly five grand on this
digital deletion tool and then watch as
some idiot runs off and dies with it in
the first eight seconds
it's actually really bad because the op
isn't just the most impactful boomstick
on the board it's the most expensive
well of the guns that people actually
use that is it's not like liquid or
holding tryouts for a primary auto
sniper rur though at this point
maybe they should be
oh god
sad times man
anyway the point is that you want your
opera to be flashy but you also want
them to be responsible and reliable
since weapons carry over i.e can be
saved
round to round what's interesting is
that for whatever reason most of csgo's
truly famous offers
are
well kind of
anything but that and has to immediately
fall back with jade he wants this
madness he's picking up behind the lines
he's gonna get the kill on sipnix and
runs away and that has to shake tsm to
be clear that is not to say that they
are bad no no no they are
animals big [ __ ] divinities who
routinely pull off idiotic irresponsible
frags without a second thought frags
that you just know were prefaced with
someone on comms saying don't worry he
wins these kenny gets stuck in the site
finding more that's brilliant and kenny
s again up close oh my goodness kenny s
the no scope on the third there are
exceptions of course but
they're just surprisingly hard to find
in fact if you can find a world-class
opera whose excellence isn't predicated
on being a showboat one who actually
excels at being ultra defensive
snatch them up because they will take
you to these stars devices had a really
rough game flashed he's gonna get that
shot and it has to feel a little bit
good out middle of the air to take down
alex and now they're pushing
[Music]
[Applause]
every oh one but james is a little
different he took his propensity for
saving to such an extreme that at some
point it looked as if his team could
actually be paralyzed by it passive
position is true to the low hp at this
point james is just looking for an
avenue
of safety
one players are on the bottom side here
from big one will tap and that should be
at least a player into the open gym has
not picked us they're just going to
defuse it
and there we go easy as it comes jim
just looks to his teammate like what the
hell was i was i meant to 45 seconds
james just sitting here it's just
waiting for a player to eventually come
through palace but the bomb is starting
to make its way forward in towards the a
bomb site eventually it is getting
planted in its existence it will be the
man to sort of risk his own life to get
yeah that's a super baldy plant now they
get an open plan that's really easy to
defend from both pit and mid yeah this
is going to be difficult
because there's so many post plant
positions established here screens
picked up a kill as well so it's back
into a 4v4 north doing damage screen
coming in with another and it's falling
apart for a vanguard it's only on james
and it's a 1v3 it's it's just too far
gone already so jim again save time for
the awp needless to say this ultra
disciplined approach
has received its fair share of criticism
i know a lot of people are excited to
see jane because obviously he's very
skilled with the op i can't get excited
watching him play
and yes a shitload of memeing james stop
beating uncomfortable so i think jaime
is the second coming of jesus and he
will save my pickums
sorry chad alright kenny
as a ct what do you do whether you
eliminated all the teas but the bomb is
planted i said yo
it's gem time
some even went so far as to dub him the
jesus of cs go since well he's got a
beard long hair
and uh
saves
get it
here's the thing though tiresome as it
was from a spectator standpoint james
painstakingly self-restrained playstyle
was actually really hard to deal with if
jane can find him with his head turned
away then that's one thing if flamie
resides in the side of the ladder then
that's another james is honing in on
this james walking forward and now he's
on for the one versus three clutch
avant-garde again
with a chance but how how does he get
himself away from this he's gonna climb
the ladder you'd think electronic may
have just been fooled by this he takes
the high road and james not yet spotted
but he's just working his way around
he's got the info he's got the shot
james 1v3
saving the op every round essentially
meant that avangar had an op every round
making it way easier to secure opening
picks and ensure that their opponents
always had to play around the damn thing
but when jane did decide to go in
he popped off will they look for this
james goes for a white peek with a
pistol that's beautiful giving james a
chance one versus one he knows exactly
where stewie is around the pillar oh
can you believe it it's kind of a
disaster yeah they're not gonna let him
go they're gonna accept right in front
of that molotov james still wants to
fight there's the jump back huge shot
bomb hits the deck
and vitality is gonna have to scramble
to recover and james coming back now has
a chance on an apex and he's got that as
well four kills in the round for james
and disaster strikes vitality
he's so hungry he's gonna eat the entire
team
ace
to take down vitality is it game time
it's game time boys
[Laughter]
by the fall of 2019 avangar had
cinderella their way to the finals of
the berlin major where they faced off
against astralis the greatest team ever
to do it the bout lasted well a solid 10
minutes it was a beat down but that was
okay no one could beat astralis back
then james is all alone
and he doesn't know where to look
doesn't know what to pay attention to
this shot
and he's gone and astralis delivering
the final uppercut but contrary to what
a lot of people thought
that was not the last that we would see
of avangar jame or his pesky penchant
for pocketing ours we've been asking
teams all day as well to give our um our
grenade challenge a go behind you can
see the little hawk the holes in the
wall there okay um there's some little
beanbags we're giving everyone three
three shots are trying to get the
highest score okay i think james gonna
hit all three you think james is gonna
hit all
by the very end of 2019 they'd caught
the attention of a virtus pro who
quickly signed them on but the advent of
the game's so-called online era
didn't exactly treat them kindly if he
gets his one-on-one this round it could
be his but no scope he's just gambling
he's just throwing his money in the
lottery and he's doing it twice i i've
lost words i've lost logic my vp have
probably lost this map for the better
part of 2020 virtus pro struggled to
regain the form that had catapulted them
to a major final and james admitted to
hltv that his save obsessed approach
might have contributed to that but after
bringing in yakindar things began to
turn around for vp and by the end of the
year they were once again looking
fearsome it seems like we might have a
bit of aggression coming through your
kinder oh my god newest addition to the
team showing up in style for the pistol
round that's a triple make that a quart
all headshots yakin duck calm down boy
can you get the ace as well
just do it there you have it in addition
to supplementing james glacially paced
opting with yakindar's hyper aggressive
entry style they'd racked up wins at
flash.2 dreamhack open december and cs
summit seven where james himself was
named mvp it's hard to figure out where
the bombs being clocked by sound when
it's on the other side of the smoke and
the fountain but here is the cavalry for
fnatic at the very least j malone one
versus three we know he's capable needs
to find the right climbing nose a nice
angle from crims but a benefit from jane
repositioning now trying to isolate
fights and
avoid the trade fragger
he's walked down from what a flick from
jw from jaime and it's 1v1 now brooklyn
has a kid does he commit to the diffuser
he's got a smoke as well could be used
pretty big
and there is the clutch from james one
versus three never counting him out by
2021 it was clear our boy was making
genuine strides when it came to holding
down the w key what's more he'd become
way less inclined to shy away from a
fight look how close they are yeah he's
gonna get one here
can't believe it's luck
anticipating a second
trying to work oh we get away oh has he
no way james gets the no scope he gets a
third he's getting him right here right
now james pops off best of all
he'd found ways to save
little less
selfishly
and and you know vp have a little more
money thanks to james sarah don't know
if he caught it jame realized he was
trapped by the scout of back boxes and
so he dropped his orb and he shot it
over to buster on ramp so he could pick
it up and get out of the round james
didn't feel like he would be able to
escape without getting taken down still
it wasn't as if virtus pro's problems
were going to disappear overnight old
habits die hard as they say and dream
time
was no exception
big up close good kill initially no luck
from buster the bomb is still at yeah
mid folks it's the old ship come on jim
you got to bring it to the site your
team are already here taking fights
come on you got to get the bomb over
here with 20 seconds left
your kinder's gonna have to try and get
a kill but what what's happening right
now your kendall's gonna do everything
and it's james just not going for it
going into iem cologne 2021 cs go's
first land in well over a year
fans were quite frankly
uninterested in fertis pro thanks in
large part to james his roster had
patented this frugal disciplined anti-cs
that made their matches long
boring to watch
and as sponge said on hltv confirmed
difficult to hype up we had some calls
like as soon as the event ends we do
like some some production meeting calls
and some some content discussions and
stuff and we're in the phone call and
we're talking about like the promo
content that we want to do right for
this week and the stuff that's been
worked on now within these four days and
vp is a topic it comes up and nobody
wants to talk about vp like i'm one of
the people who's like like i'm on the
call they're like okay so what's cool
about vp and i'm like
i don't know nothing's cool like we've
already done the ukinder thing to death
right we've done the kind of thing
together virtus pro weren't so much
playing to win as they were playing not
to lose and at a time when the community
was already discussing whether official
matches were too long the fact that they
were winning was tilting to a sizable
number of cs go fans the question was
whether jaime and his compatriots
actually gave a [ __ ]
winning is great don't get me wrong
but
is it really worth being hated over
say what you will about virtus pro's
play style it secured them a top six
finish at what was undeniably the most
important counter-strike tournament
in like
forever while their stingy sniper may be
a bit of a bore
christ is he hard to beat advertised pro
are one round away from being eliminated
from iem cologne without a single map
win challenge into jam he's got one in
the awp another one for james he's going
to try and take everybody down and dream
late into the night he's still
frightened like a madman he goes boosted
up but your kidnaps ready another
headshot for him and config is
desperately scrambling trying to find
his kill but buster will close it blmf
is alone flashed into the site and they
are eliminated from intel extreme
masters cologne complexity exit early
and virtus pro stay alive we'll be back
after the break to break this one down
thanks to their remarkable showing at
cologne
vp have proven that they are a
world-class roster with a world-class
opera at the helm and as cs go slowly
but surely returns to regular land
competition
the question is whether virtus pro will
ever have what it takes to be the best
by toppling their opposition
one
save at a time securing this one it's
only kicker and james
and only kick it with the first
now a second perhaps they can finish it
right here right now up against the odds
james to finish the job as only sphinx
missing his shot oh no way
that he's a disaster
though at this point
maybe they should be
i'm just i'm just kidding i love you
guys i'm swearing i love you guys i'm
just kidding you don't have to use these
i'm just like just in case you feel
because i feel so bad and i love liquids
so much i don't want them to [ __ ]
hate me
i'm not trying to actually they're our
only team bro they're nacs's only tier
one team like we
like positive
it i i hope like i'm not trying to be a
dick but something's gotta change man
they gotta it's not working like